- [Narrator] Games.
We've been playing them forever.
But why?
- Games are fun.
- [Narrator] Okay.
But, what else?
- Nature takes play very seriously.
Play offers safe practice
for learning the skills
you need to do things
that in nature may even
relate to your survival.
(whimsical music)
- [Narrator] This is Matt.
- Oh, hi.
I'm Matt Miller, and I think you should
ditch that textbook.
- [Narrator] And this is Joe and Kama.
Guys?
(clears throat)
- You ready? Okay.
- My name is Kama Tothero.
- And my name is Joe Tothero.
- We are avid game enthusiasts.
- [Narrator] These guys
are experts in finding
real world lessons in existing games.
Games like Clash of Clans.
And they're using these
lessons to turn game play
into a universal learning
tool through a theory
called Constructivism.
- Constructivism basically says you need
to be put in situations that allow you
to construct your
understanding of a particular
topic or phenomenon.
- We're constructing.
We're making up what we
know the world to be.
That's kinda constantly changing.
We're adding new things into our paradigm
of what we think the world
is, and that's really
what education's all about.
- [Broadcaster] Here is a
third grade on a field trip
to get first hand knowledge
of their questions in science.
- If we have play pulled into all of that.
If we use games to be
able to learn in that way,
that's that inherently
interesting, inherently fun
way to do that, but
they don't even realize
that they're learning when they are.
- That can be true of video games as well,
depending on the type of video game.
Games that you really want to start with
that have the high ROI
are cooperative games.
In a cooperative game, the game itself is
trying to defeat you, and
you do need to work together,
and coordinate your efforts.
Clash of Clans is a good
example of a cooperative game
because you have a clan.
You want your other clan mates to do well.
All boats rise in Clash.
As you play some of
these games, you see the
very specific skills and competencies
that can be developed
if you leverage the game
intentionally in that direction.
- Clash of Clans was
unavoidable in my class.
And of course, as a
teacher I started to think
about how could that play into my lesson.
And so I started to create sort of like
a review game.
And so whenever they would
answer questions correctly
the would earn points.
But the thing that came
from Clash of Clans
was they built up those points
to be able to buy things.
And, they loved it.
- It's an investment
portfolio, and it supports
your choice making in terms
of long term investment
and savings, short term
investment, and that's not
just for kids.
You see it with kids, but
you also see it with adults.
Adults can get better
at this stuff by playing
these types of games.
So when you break it down
to individual mechanics,
you think about in terms of resources.
What are the resources available to me.
So Clash has elixir,
dark elixir, and gold.
- Clash is really good
at presenting choices for
both immediate gain, and delayed gain.
- So there is that famous
marshmallow experiment
where you put a marshmallow
in front of a kid
and say, okay, you can
eat the marshmallow now,
or you can wait.
And if you keep that
marshmallow in ten minutes
I'll give you another
marshmallow, and you'll
have two instead of one.
Some kids are able to
delay the gratification
and say, okay, I'm gonna wait for that
second marshmallow.
That's great.
Others are like, I'm
eating the marshmallow.
- Oh, I love the marshmallow experiment.
You know, delayed
gratification in our society
is something that all of
us really struggle with.
If you know why you're playing it, and you
know what you're getting out of it,
then sometimes you can learn lessons
by playing video games
that you can't learn
a lot of other ways.
- There is so much
available right now that
you can pull off the shelf or download and
develop some ideas about
how that connects to
skills in the workplace.
You don't have to go all the way.
- [Broadcaster] The chance
to play is essential
to the wellbeing of
all, regardless of age.
- Surely the games may change over time,
but we in our desire to play together and
have immersive experiences
in being community; we've
been doing that forever.
- Having people play
cooperative games where
it enhances their communication,
enhances leadership.
Cooperative games are a rich
vein to mine in that regard.
- In a way, more effective
than a trust fall.
- Yes. Yeah.